since the launch of goop in 2008 Gwyneth
Paltrow has continued to make headlines
with her controversial and sometimes
ridiculous takes on wellness and health
granted most people when they see a
headline about vaginal eggs or steaming
groins tend to chuckle and just move on
and while you might unfortunately not
everyone does so let's talk about why
this hundred billion dollar Wellness
industry continues to thrive and the
actual danger it poses to their
customers let's start with the art of
persuasion I have used ozone therapy
rectally what is that unscientific
unproven potentially harmful therapies
that's a razor Thin Line to have to
tread across between scientific evidence
and just merely entertaining it's been
known to make some slightly
pseudosciencey claims poop is taking
advantage of people at their most
vulnerable positions and it's really
just not acceptable when an influential
celebrity enters the scene a Reptilian
Brain begins to take over it's actually
a known psychological phenomenon that
familiar faces like those of celebs tend
to be more trusted this is likely a
survival mechanism to distrust strange
enemies and instead trust those in our
tribes however I can assure you these
celebrities are far from your tribe so
one of my bathrooms has to be different
because you took my 10 marble slabs
celebrities will pose their advice as
simply what they do or what works for
them while simultaneously building
enormous businesses that profit off
their innocent storytelling it's not
meant to be advice for anybody else it's
really just what has worked for me but
still buy your products using link in
BIO right but Dr Mike what's the harm if
they're just sharing what works for them
and making a profit there's nothing
wrong with making a profit except if
it's profiting off of misinformation
under the guise of questionable anecdote
at best at worst it delays people from
getting actual medical treatment think
about it it's not unreasonable to have a
person with stomach problems seek help
from unproven supplements while cancer
spreads throughout their body this isn't
an exaggeration either in 2017 a study
published in the Journal of the National
Cancer Institute showed that people with
cancer who would use alternative
medicine instead of conventional
treatment had a greater risk of dying
it's not just a delay in getting real
Medical Care these unregulated
treatments potentially create harm like
medication interactions liver
inflammation heart arrhythmias or even
an increased risk of getting cancer yes
cancer yet somehow this industry is
expected to grow to 400 plus billion
dollars by 2030. and honestly I think
it's my fault well not my fault but
modern medicines fault truly our Health
Care system has provided us with nothing
short of a garbage experience we have
shrinking appointment times burnt out
Physicians and corrupt insurance plans
that leave people wanting an alternative
to regular medicine I get it but you
know what bothers me even more is that
many of these companies Target women in
their advertising my theory as to why
they know women have been hurt even more
by the traditional Health Care System
they get misdiagnosed more often even in
life or death moments like heart attacks
their bodies are poorly understood as a
result of less inclusion in research and
education and their physical pain is not
taking nearly as seriously and it
doesn't stop there these companies prey
unknown insecurities they promise
unrealistic Beauty outcomes that most of
the time at least on social media are
achieved through plastic surgery
injections and phase two not their
Miracle product let's not skim over that
detail
bombastic side eye so now let's look at
some of Gwyneth Paltrow's Wellness
claims and goo products that landed her
in hot water with doctors and agencies
like the NHS
the infamous jadeg goop claimed that
inserting this egg-shaped Stone into the
vagina could improve sexual health
balance hormones and even prevent
uterine prolapse the problem there's
absolutely no scientific evidence to
back these claims in fact using a jade
egg can lead to infections and even
toxic shock syndrome so this product got
destroyed by the medical community and
goop ended up paying 145 thousand
dollars to settle the false advertising
claim and reimburse any customer who
actually bought the product
just last month Gwen appeared on a
podcast where she admitted one of her
very helpful Wellness treatments had
been rectal ozone therapy a process of
having gas injected into the rectum in
the hopes of reducing oxidative stress
and a whole host of other miraculous
health benefits however according to the
FDA ozone is a toxic gas with no known
useful medical applications in specific
adjunctive or preventive therapies even
the U.S code of regulations isn't shy
about the proven effects of ozone on
humans although undesirable
physiological effects on the central
nervous system heart and vision had been
reported the predominant physiological
effect of ozone is primary irritation of
the mucous membranes so irritation of
the rectum I think twice
in 2021 Gwen felchi was suffering
lingering effects of covid-19 and a year
later was still noticing symptoms like
brain fog and fatigue long covid is a
serious and deeply complex condition
that certainly requires more research
but not if you're Gwen who went on to
describe her recovery routine designed
by Will Cole her chiropractor who
criticizes Pharma for being profit
driven and sells a hundred ninety seven
dollar gut supplement and a 724 toxin
home test
Gwen detailed every step of her long
coveted recovery process
enthusiastically listing the products
for sale alongside her writing on goop's
website such as the goop Wellness box
for 265 dollars for her infrared sauna
blanket in stock for six hundred dollars
free shipping though when asked about
Gwen's long covet cure Dr Steven powis
the national medical director for
England's NHS stated that like a virus
misinformation carries across borders
and it mutates and it evolves goop's
editors were quick to point out that
this was one person's story and recounts
an individual experience it is not meant
to be a diagnosis for healing or
treating any specific disease symptoms
or side effects at least that was honest
goop has written favorably about the
stickers that promote healing one of
their blog posts promotes wearable
stickers from body Vibes such as the
anti-anxiety 10 pack which fill in the
deficiencies in your reserves creating a
calming effect group log Riders did
leave a warning though saying leaving
them on for the prescribed three-day
period left a few group staffers with
marks on their skin so be careful to
stick them on somewhere concealable if
you got an event coming up well as a
practicing physician I would have put a
warning that this is complete horseshoe
and that anxiety can be a real problem
that has legitimate Solutions you can
pursue with your doctor and unless trust
me bro is a form of evidence there is
zero evidence that wearing stickers will
reduce your anxiety
goop currently sells 135 dollar implanto
Rama coffee enema this device is used in
the bathroom to shoot coffee up into
your rectum and colon via the anus with
claims that the coffee can be used to
clean out your digestive system there is
no evidence of any medical benefit to
this product and they actually know that
too because their website clearly states
no claims are made about this product or
anything we sell on this website when
using any new procedure that you do not
understand always check with a competent
medical doctor which surprise surprise I
am and why I'm pleased to inform you
that this is a complete waste of money
and just when you thought your coffee
couldn't get any more expensive
goop has proudly promoted vaginal
steaming a process of sitting above a
steaming pot of water attempting to
cleanse your uterus in 2015 goop said
you sit on what is essentially a mini
throw and a combination of infrared and
mugwort steam cleanses your uterus
several problems with this first the
vagina is self-cleaning it doesn't need
any help if you happen to develop an
infection you should visit a doctor to
diagnose and treat the issue next add
moisture to the vagina in the form of
steam can actually lead to the growth of
bacteria actually increasing your risk
of infection and sadly some women have
actually burned their vaginas due to the
steam being too hot
in 2015 goo published a piece written by
Dr Habib sadagi who introduced a link
between underwire bras and breast cancer
a long debunked Claim by numerous
medical organizations Dr sedaki wrote a
long quote that ended with accumulated
toxins anywhere in the body increased
the risk for cancer the American Cancer
Society disagreed confirming there is no
scientific or clinical basis for this
claim goop has since removed the article
look not all natural remedies are snake
oil I made a video where I discussed the
ones that actually work on our evidence
base click here to check that out and as
always stay happy and healthy
thank you
[Applause]